- Welcome, welcome, welcome
to another exciting
edition of Market Takes.
We are looking forward out at the week.
Thank you so much for being with us.
I know you could have
been anywhere in the world
but you are here with me
and I appreciate that.
I'm Dion Rabouin, reporter
at the Wall Street Journal
your host for Market Takes.
And look, there is going to
be a lot happening this week.
We got a huge week of data
but I'm gonna tell you
what the three most important things are
that are happening this week.
First things first, the
first one is inflation.
We get two big reports on
inflation this week, CPI and PPI.
I'll tell you what those are,
what you need to look for in those.
Second, we will be hearing from the IMF,
the International Monetary
Fund and the World Bank
on the state of the global economy.
I'll tell you what to watch and listen for
throughout the week of meetings
as well as what reports are
gonna be coming from that.
Third, we will get the
first earnings reports
from the largest US banks,
that's coming on Friday.
That's gonna tell us a lot
about not just the economy
and the market but that's
gonna tell us a lot
about this bank run, these bank collapses
that we've been seeing,
this movement of money
across the banking system.
We are gonna hear from those big banks
and we are gonna learn a
lot about what's going on
with the banks and how
that looks through the eyes
of those banks and what
that could tell us.
That's gonna tell us a
lot about the economy.
So listen, let's get into it.
First things first,
inflation out this week.
We get the CPI, the Consumer Price Index.
I wanna put this chart
here up on your screen
that's just gonna, it shows
you what we've seen from CPI.
Now, going back to March
2022, where we start this,
you saw inflation had already picked up
and there was an expectation that, okay,
we'd hit peak inflation,
but then nope, you see
it picks back up there.
And then in June we hit that 9.1% number.
And ever since then
we've been coming down,
coming down, coming down.
And economists predict
that inflation for March,
for March 2023, will be about 5.2%.
Now that's down from 6% in February
and down from 6.4% in January.
You see that just continual
decline of inflation on the CPI.
And that just illustrates,
this chart up here,
shows you how inflation
has consistently come down
over the past year.
It's done that month over month as well.
Economists predict that we'll
see 0.3% inflation for March.
That's after 0.4% in
February and 0.5% in January.
Now, one thing you wanna watch out for
when we get this CPI report
is the core CPI number,
that strips out volatile
food and energy prices.
And that's gonna be a big number,
because economists actually
expect that to rise.
Now, overall inflation
you saw in that chart
had been coming back down
and economists expect that to continue.
But core, stripping out
volatile food and energy prices,
is expected to rise for the
first time since September.
That could be big
because it could alter what
the Federal Reserve is thinking
and how they're looking at inflation.
You're gonna wanna watch out for that.
Also important within this
CPI report is gonna be
the movement of gas prices.
We have seen gas prices, the
average across the country
has risen to about 360 per gallon.
And out in California, it's approaching
that $5 per gallon average
throughout the state.
So oil prices start to pick back up.
The decline in oil prices
has been a big part of why
inflation has declined.
It's been a big part of
why consumer sentiment
has been rebounding.
And now we are starting to
see those gas prices pick up.
We're seeing oil on the market
at about $80 per barrel.
Saudi Arabia and OPEC
announced a surprise cut in production.
That could push gas prices up.
You're gonna wanna watch that.
Now, the other thing
you're gonna wanna
watch out for this week,
CPI comes out on Wednesday,
Thursday we get PPI or
the Producer Price Index.
Want to throw that chart
up here on your screen
to give you a look.
Now, PPI has really led CPI.
It's been about a month ahead
and we've seen the trends.
Now you see there that same kind of trend,
but you see things moving higher.
On the PPI report, June
was over 10%, around 11%.
PPI inflation, that's what
businesses are paying producers.
It's AKA, what this report is also known
as the Wholesale Price Report.
So it's what businesses
are paying for labor,
their inputs, all those things,
when they go out and buy
and then they turn
around mark the prices up
and sell them to us.
So that's been a leading indicator
of what overall inflation
will be for consumers.
That's expected to
decline to 4.4% in March.
So again, as it led CPI going
up, it's now expected to lead.
It has led CPI coming down,
that's expected to continue.
So this charge just illustrates
what we've seen for business prices,
the PPI over the last year,
and that trend is expected to continue.
One thing that I think has
been really interesting
is, you know, while
inflation is still very high
compared to historical norms
or at least the norms
over the past 20 years,
it seems like a lot of folks
aren't really talking about it.
Wanna put one more chart
here up on your screen
and this is a chart of Google trends,
and this is just how many
people are searching for this
compared to how many people
searched for it historically.
You see that big pickup there in August,
that's that giant spike, you see,
that's actually after
the big peak in inflation
that happened in June, and ever since then
it's been just kind of
consistently declining.
Look, inflation is not over.
Inflation is still very far
from the Fed's 2% target,
it was at 6% we saw in
February, even at 5.2%.
If economists are correct, we
are still a long ways from 2%.
So that chart up there
just illustrating kind
of a an interesting theme
that I'm seeing
which is folks not really being worried,
not looking up, not Googling inflation.
That's definitely
something to watch out for.
Also, we are gonna get the FOMC minutes,
the minutes from the
Fed's last policy meeting.
Those are out on Wednesday
as well, along with CPI.
Definitely something to keep your eye on.
We'll be right here, Wednesday
morning, 10:00 AM Eastern,
doing market takes,
breaking down that CPI,
Consumer Price Index, report on inflation.
I hope you'll be with us as well.
The second thing you need to
be watching out for this week
is the IMF and World Bank Spring meetings.
Those are gonna kick off this week.
We've got the World Economic
Outlook released on Tuesday.
That's the IMF's big picture
look at what's going on
with the globe and of
course, the economic trends.
In the last update, in January,
they said they saw a,
quote, "turning point"
for global growth.
They raised their expectations,
improved the outlook.
Now overall, global growth
is expected to slow from 3.4%
last year to 2.9% this year.
We'll see if they revise that.
Maybe there's an even rosier outlook.
But the one thing that you
worry about with a rosy outlook
is that could show a pickup for inflation.
Definitely something to
keep your eye out on.
Previously, the World Bank has warned
of a quote, "lost decade"
for global growth,
especially in emerging markets.
Talking about how things
like the war in Ukraine,
the COVID-19 pandemic, and
of course high inflation,
have impacted the overall theme
of how the globe can grow.
They're saying that, you know,
the potential growth from
2000, 2010 had been about 3.5%.
Then from 2011 to 2021
that had dropped to 2.6%.
Now the expectation is that
that potential growth output
will shrink to 2.2%.
When there's not as much growth,
businesses can't grow as much,
incomes can't grow as much.
Folks aren't able to build
their wealth as much.
And you see things just kind
of get worse for everybody.
We had seen a long running trend
of continual poverty
alleviation, wealth accumulation,
poor countries have been
growing a lot richer,
and that's a bonus for
everyone around the world,
including us here in wealthy countries
like the US, Europe,
Japan, things like that.
That's been slowing down,
and that's definitely
something to watch out for,
big picture when you
look around the globe.
Also worries about inflation
potentially coming back.
Definitely something
to keep your eye out on
for these IMF and World Bank
meetings coming up this week.
That kicks off on Tuesday
with a WEO report,
as they call it, World Economic Outlook.
And then Wednesday you
got the big meeting,
IMF managing director,
Kristalina Georgieva
World Bank President, David
Malpass, look out for that.
Finally, the third thing
that you need to be watching
out for, bank earnings.
We get those starting on Friday.
The big names, JPMorgan Chase,
Wells Fargo, Citi, BlackRock
PNC Bank, BNY Mellon, the
trillion dollar teams.
They are all gonna be out
with their reports this week.
Not all of 'em have a
trillion dollars in assets.
Just a couple of them, just
so I don't get any emails,
'cause I know y'all like to talk.
But those big banks will be out
with their internet reports on Friday.
This is gonna tell us a lot
about this worrisome banking
crisis, banking collapse,
bank run, whatever you want to call it.
How much of that money
flowed into these big banks
from some of the regional
and smaller banks?
We hopefully will get
some information on that.
And what does this tell us
about the state of the banking sector?
Are these banks doing something
useful with that capital?
Are they saying, okay, we're
moving into more risky assets,
that might be something
worrisome to watch out for,
you know, and this is
overall gonna tell us
how were they feeling about this deposits.
Remember I told you guys a while back
banks don't want your money.
The big banks, they have enough money,
they really don't even know
what to do with this money.
Crazy problem to have.
But it is one that the
big banks are having.
They got too much money.
Now, they got even more.
What are they doing with it?
We're also gonna talk about
how much they accessed,
how much the big banks accessed,
the Fed's discount window.
Did they borrow a lot
of money from the Fed?
We've seen $400 billion in increase
in the Fed's balance sheet,
how much of that went to big banks?
Finally, we are gonna see
their loan loss provisions.
How much of the big banks worried
about losing money on loans?
Are they putting a lot
of money to the side
and saying, okay, we think a lot of people
aren't gonna be able to
pay back their loans.
That's something to look out for.
Hey listen, that's gonna do it
for us here on Market Takes.
I appreciate you guys so
much for being with us.
I am Dion Rabouin, reporter
at the Wall Street Journal.
I know you could have been
anywhere in the world,
but you're here with me.
I thank you for that.
We hope you'll be with us on Wednesday
when we do it again next
time on Market Takes.